[Music]
by now you
probably understand that google
customizes a lot of our data center
design
this customization traces back to the
beginning of a data center story
where it lives so how do we select our
data center sites
data center site selection is all about
balancing a variety of factors
a data center location has to have the
right combination of energy
infrastructure
proximity to our users available
workforce
and available land some of our data
center campuses are the size of hundreds
of american football fields
yeah that's a lot of touchdowns one of
the first things to assess is exposure
to natural disasters
areas that are prone to earthquakes
extreme weather events
or floods aren't good candidates to
house thousands of machines
though sometimes it's unavoidable for
what we're looking for so we accommodate
through our designs
in case unexpected scenarios arise we've
designed for redundant power supplies
and data replication
fiber network connectivity is another
factor understanding latency limits and
distance to nearby points of presence
or network access points is a major
piece of the puzzle
and since power is a high ongoing cost
and impacts the environment we always
search for
reliable and efficient carbon free
energy options
to ensure sustainable operations around
the clock
areas with temperate climates or other
suitable environments provide
options for 100 outdoor air or water
cooling
to augment or replace mechanical air
conditioning
and add a cherry on top finding sites
with unique geographic qualities
can improve environmental performance
for example
our data center in belgium uses recycled
water from a nearby industrial canal
to cool its servers making it more
sustainable and
the first google data center to
eliminate refrigerated cooling
in finland we transformed an old paper
mill located next to the bay of finland
into a data center the bay's water
sitting at 57 degrees
fahrenheit or 14 degrees celsius all
year round
allows us to use sea water to cool the
data center
our taiwan data center is one of asia's
most efficient
and environmentally friendly our
nighttime cooling and thermal energy
storage system
cools water at night when temperatures
are lower storing it in large insulated
tanks then during the day it's pumped
throughout the facility to cool our
servers
thanks in part to our partnership with
dutch farmer cooperatives
our data center in the netherlands
sources carbon-free power directly from
local wind farms our data center in
ireland
uses an advanced air cooling system that
takes advantage of ireland's temperate
weather
to keep our servers running smoothly as
a result
the data center can be cooled
efficiently with outdoor air
instead of air conditioning units as you
can see
there's no one-size-fits-all for google
data centers
each one is built to adapt to local
strengths and thrive
but what does this mean for you at home
and our real world applications
find out next time on discovering data
[Music]
centers
you